[Music]
if you give him confidence
you give him good words he will he will
be the best
but it's all about screaming shocks
because g2's have the luxury of having
these guys peaking at the moment
okay i'm not supposed to be a captain
like it started in my
first 90s i tried and it was
a good experience i can bring way more
as a player
that i can as a captain in the team
[Music]
that's a deadly kill goes for the second
and he's moving closer
looking for the quad chair for next the
last man alive he's gonna tap the bomb
once
sounds a cold
[Music]
what a god
lives and breathes counter-strike born
in france in 1992
he discovered the game at nine years old
and it gripped him
by his mid-teens he was competing in
france's domestic counter-strike scene
and incredibly convinced his parents to
support his attempt to become a pro
[Music]
under
in the years after source's release most
of the competitive world eventually went
back to the older 1.6
but shocks his native france did not and
it was building one of the strongest
competitive scenes for source in the
world to start for the
for the french css player it was very
tough because we
wasn't we weren't respected by uh by
other
criticized players from the 1.6 and we
we wanted to earn their respect you know
and to be a
successful in that environment shock
showed off incredible aim
strong instincts and the ability to
clutch out lopsided situations
and he was starting to turn heads uh i
was the first to
to say this guy is gonna be he's gonna
be a [ __ ] god of the game so
i think he and i was i was not
a type of guy would give a lot of
respect to a young player and that early
success led to some pretty big
opportunities
including the chance to play with the
frenchie's best igls like existence and
krl
and even represent his country in
international competition
he started to get a reputation and his
teams built around his abilities
but shox was still young and an
emotional player
he was clearly one of his region's
brightest stars but when he was 20 years
old
he faced a new challenge
[Music]
when cs go was announced the source and
1.6 scenes were reunited in a new game
one where france's legacy of source
excellence was tested
shocks entered cs go as part of
millennium and both his squad and very
games were seen as the french scene's
biggest hopes
but it was very games who proved
themselves as the region's best team
and with that one of the best in the
world
while ninjas and pajamas dominated this
early stage of cs go
they were routinely pushed to the limit
by very games
but shocks struggled to find a home he
bounced from imaginary gaming to tcm
gaming
and even tried an international mix team
that included one lotuslove
guardian kovach even when his teams did
poorly
sharks was able to show his individual
skills were still sharp
get himself a kill on dreamy and locks
replies back we're at two versus two
double great g grenade into the bomb
site disposes of two
epsilon players shocks he picks them
both up all the while
he watched vari games from afar he knew
that eventually
their inability to defeat nip might
provoke change
eventually shocks got the call from vari
games and he replaced a young
up and coming talent by the name of
kenny s it wasn't the first time that
sharks had played under the very game's
banner
during source back in 2011 he had been
removed from the roster due to internal
issues
but the team's early performance showed
that drama had been left behind
they got into shape fast defeating
virtus pro at esl one
summer 2013 about a month after sharks
joined the team
gotta land the shots and gotta do it
quickly here 30 seconds remaining
shock shows in his head that's cheeky
the two men who have played together
and don't play together anymore nvk
with the final kill g
g and it's fiji all the way
very games are your recall ems 1
champions
sharks himself earned mvp at starladder
star series 7 for an incredible
performance and a 1.61 kd ratio
and when the team needed it shocks was
there
right now he's taken down one can he
find shocks
1v1 right now he needs the hat trick to
keep his team in this
shock steps away not gonna happen sharks
takes his team
into the finals and he's taken to the
absolute top
of this league that was absolutely
incredible stuff from very games they
are the winners of the raid call ems one
2013 full
finals the search came at the right time
with dreamhack winner 2013
the first cs go major a month away and
though they came forth losing to nip
again
it looked like maybe french cs had
established itself and go
i can't see him god see him looks for
the frenchman
has a guess he's gonna try and bait him
out with the defuse and pushes around
the corner
oh smith gets it the romance
is over the french have gone through
they will face nip tomorrow
hltv named shocks the third best player
of 2013
citing impressive personal stats and
team impact
as the roster moved to the titan
organization they posted more important
victories
but also a disappointing group stage
exit at the next major in ketovicha
coming up huge pick up the killers to
kill you get another one smith the last
man standing in a one-on-three
as doji is sitting inside a pit and
titans have fallen
the titans are getting knocked out of
group a and are not advancing on
we are going to see virtus pro and
hellraisers and fans out of group a who
the hell would have thought titans would
have been here
shock said he was unhappy with the
difficulties that living in a team house
put on his relationship
and he left titan after a short stint
with epsilon esports where sharks
attended his third consecutive major
the first french shuffle began the scene
had contended with the world's best at
the beginning of cs go but it was
running out of steam
and the results at esl one cologne
proved it and it'll be
existing get right at fryeburg and
they're only one frag away from the
final
it's kaylee versus nip can he deliver no
ninjas in pajamas charged into the grand
final
the obvious answer was to try some new
player combinations while maintaining
the region's close-knit relationships
so shocks along with happy nbk kiyoshima
and smiths
formed ldlc's new roster in september of
2014.
fans waited to see whether they could be
better than the new titan or
epsilon lineups and whether any of them
could become the world's best
they wouldn't have to wait long
dreamhack winner 2014
the next major was only a few months
away and in the late up
ldlc looked hot but slowly but surely
navi seems to be gaining some ground but
kyoshima
two huge kills and ldlc on the brink
of winning star series 11 against navi
it's just guardian that stands between
them and victory and he will go down
16-6 on the final map and it's going to
be a victory
for ldlc they're going to go home with
13 000
but with the other two best french
squads sidelined by vac bans
it was on shocks and ldlc to bring home
france's first
cs go major given the round loss bonus
but it's not cool i think that's the
right choice
close range here's shots gonna be at the
first kill they almost line it up he's
got the all part again he's just hiding
in the smoke how is this man still alive
and he's gonna try to scope he lives
through the round
you've got to be kidding me now it's
down to midnight one on five
sharks should not be living right now
miss and kiyoshima opening up great
double kill for mars in hand it's a
triple
he goes for more kiyoshima with four
kills to clean up the incoming sea set
push
so good at it follow-up from happy he
goes for it again he wants a second can
he catch it as well
stunning shot from happy there in an
incredible fashion in
the time on the last map against nip
this is all on get right
there might be the perfect man to have
left here
trying to walk in pacing himself he's
going to spot
nbk first he goes down at ldlc they pick
it up
oh look at that they can hardly believe
it they're hugging each other and it
must be an unreal sensation
it was france's first cs go major and it
came with a hard-fought overtime win
over the perennial terrors
ninjas and pajamas as shocks hoisted the
trophy it seemed as if france had
finally found the magic combination that
could hold down the world's top spot
and as the roster joined a new org team
envious
they kept on winning a top four
placement at esl one katowice was
disappointing only because
the team failed to defend their major
title but they won
several big events around that time
shocks began to experiment with in-game
leading
playing his way mostly by feel instead
of micromanaging his team
but their dominance waned and the french
scene once again began a major shuffle
the first one gave shocks a major but
this time kenny s's envious roster
reaped the benefits
four players remain here for nfe and
they're going to be pressing on to this
site and
it's an ideal situation for them but mbk
removes zeus and it's not looking good
on the second head shoulder flame gonna
be gone
there it
of is and the second title ever for
three of these players the first for
penny
and apache what a victory shocks
rejoined titan
and they weren't a bad team but they
failed to break into the finals at big
events
by early 2016 racked by the financial
followed
their former player cali's vac ban the
organization folded
and g2 esports stepped into the void
they left behind
but rather than simply play as the
team's superstar shocks wanted to
continue to igl over the previous nine
years
he had spent time under great french
in-game leaders like existence and happy
and had learned early in his career from
krl
and maybe even before existence left the
team there were signs that sharks wanted
to be the player
his teammates could rely on
and for those watching his career since
the beginning it was a familiar sight
i think sharks like me as an engagement
because i always try to give him
a lot of love and confidence you know i
was before the game i said
i look at him in his eyes it sucks
you're the best man yeah there is no one
better better
than you here so let's [ __ ] them let's
[ __ ] them together okay
if you give him confidence you give him
good words
he will he will be the best this 2016
version of g2 was a scrappy and
surprising roster
a well-established synergy between
shocks and scream let them steal away
rounds that seemed lost
he tries to go hunting once more shocks
he might get caught in the opening no
they look the wrong way apex expects to
rap they've been stacking that long so
much and sharks has sprayed down three
he's got four the round goes to g2
now shot splashed he has to back off the
angle smith's two it's allowed cloud9
out but well to their own death so far
screams
poor shroud off shocks a little pinned
in here but allowed to operate and
that's worrying cloud9 have to deal with
them and now they turn around there's
too late
shocks the absolute railgun comes in
again with the meat
in this real battle here scream as well
finds two
and now nothing's a little like the
party and about to be pushed creeping
his way back in its scream that punishes
it
two gamers is back indeed screaming
shots the only ones that are chiming in
there take these duels
and it's just luminosity systematically
shutting him down triple kill for fallen
who has been carrying his team he is the
captain here and he has been top
fragging for a very long time here on
dust2
it's on shot [ __ ] at 103 to try and keep
it alive otherwise we'll go to a fifth
map in the grand finals
shots tabs out one that's a deadly kill
goes for the second and he's moving
closer
looking for the quad clutch here fnx the
last man alive he's going to tap the
bomb once
you've got to be kidding he takes the
quad kill
they didn't place well at the majors in
columbus or cologne but
they made some finals appearances
elsewhere and even won the inaugural ecs
finals to the tune of 250 000
it's gonna be so hard this setup is so
strong the defense seems immovable at
the moment
luminosity must break it with just two
check knives and they're forced to go in
and they are being slaughtered
it is just taco now 19 health with that
second nine and there's too much to do
and too little to do with 16-5 g2
are your easiest season one champions
still the second half of the year showed
that regardless of shark's view on
leadership
the team needed more firepower a group
stage exit at the major in atlanta
was the last straw 15 rounds for the
danish team one more kill
and it's gonna be 16 they'll move on
here in the group stage they're not
through yet
and that's it config with the final kill
16-9
as they knock g2 out of this major
tournament
semmler i cannot wait for this french
shuffle
i want someone to come and shave save
shoxy here he
he definitely needs it throughout his
career shocks his played with almost
every great player in the french scene
but there was one notable exception
and when the third french shuffle began
the inevitable became reality
shocks and kenny s were now teammates
on paper at least this was a true french
super team
and the fact that the fabled kenny
shocks combination would finally see the
stage
was even more exciting but the field in
cs was more competitive than it
had ever been the danish scene which had
experienced shuffles of their own
had a serious dream team in astralis and
other contenders like north
and there were plenty of other top tier
organizations too
the team got off to a great start
victories at dreamhack
open tours 2017 the esl pro league
season 5 finals
and dreamhack masters malmo 2017 showed
the team's potential
as a top squad but the wins were
outnumbered by disappointing tournament
exits
but in the end what lacked throughout
the year was
you know consistency whether it is
for attitude work ethic or just purely
in-game to do things when they were
working the exact same way
tournament of the tournament while
shocks had still attended every major to
date
he was beginning to get very used to
only playing the group stage
then in early 2018 he made it to the
quarterfinals of the boston major
only to be defeated by the eventual
winners cloud9
he almost went down himself there's body
picking it up and now it's a one versus
one
stewie versus kenny the smell of gunfire
and freedom in the air and stewie
picking up that kill
and cloud9 are in the semi-finals oh my
god what a story they shut down g2
almost flawlessly still shocks was
statistically g2's best player in both
phases of the tournament
but g2 weren't winning and tensions in
the team
were becoming apparent we had a lot of
uh big personalities uh into the team
which means a lot of people
need space in the game and um and so now
i want to put the team in a position
where as a group we're gonna have the
same goal same motivation
same view of the game and uh and then
just
[ __ ] go for it like it is time to
just you know
stop thinking about extra things that
don't really matter because we're not at
the level where
we're winning right now so shocks
admitted that he had tried to remove and
became
apex and when that didn't work and nbk
became the new igl
shox decided not to play with the roster
uh by replacing them
i wanted existence as a team captain
and smith coming back as a player as a
main rifle
and not an ev and [ __ ] a vp he will
definitely let that to kenny
the team didn't really want to make
changes right
and so uh he decided himself that he
didn't want
to you know try it with me as an
incubator and uh so that's where
that's why he's you know not a probably
the roster in addition to riding the
bench
he needed surgery for a wrist injury nbk
had the reins for the time being
and shocks had to watch and wait but
still
like if i will have to get the surgery
about my leg about my ass or whatever
like i won't give a [ __ ]
but since it's my wrist and if you just
take away my wrist uh i don't know what
i'm gonna do and chalks was also
doubting his decision to be a leader
okay i'm not supposed to be a captain
like it's not in my
personalities you know like i'm someone
who is really shy in the
in the real world i would say uh and who
don't often i don't like to push people
nbk had his chance as igl
but the organization brought shocks back
to the lineup in june
adding existence as the new leader but
the new lineup didn't work out
further changes bringing young guns like
lucky and jax
didn't make things any better either
after nearly four years
shocks was out of the team in september
of 2019
fans could be excused for feeling that
the french csgo scene had tried 8
000 different combinations of the same
players and created an even
higher percentage of bad memories but
this time
instead of flipping the board over they
found new pieces
new young talent was on the rise and it
was sorely
needed i think the the problem we had
the last year is we don't give a lot of
uh
a lot of trust to the young player you
know it's very hard to say okay we're
gonna take mizuta he's 17
and we're going to play a big event
measure and things you know it's hard to
he did a lot of land in france i i play
with him online
he's a little monster he's a little
shocked but you never know
he's going to be shocked he's going to a
player like shocks it's gonna be like
some someone who's you know who is
just good or not good enough or you know
or just
so so it's really up to to trust young
players and i think that was the main
problem in france last year
we were always like you like you said
like we had
12 15 players who we mix each other
and we didn't have we don't have a lot
of good leaders so when sharks joined
team vitality
there was some understandable excitement
france's greatest rifler was teaming up
with zywoo
an odd talent who might very well
represent the future
of french cs but jax was already 27
he had played over five years of source
before go was even released
the question was what could fans expect
only has a defuse kit there's just no
way surely there's no way
just down to waksick now he's the only
man standing
vitality have done it they've broken the
streak and they've taken moscow
and the epicenter championship 2019.
we've seen flashes of the young sharks
but there are three players coming
around the corner someone's going to hit
the shot and they do
response from shocks time is low he's
got a second the models are burning and
shocks is setting him alive
four kills for shocks oh holy [ __ ] he
might just do it
this is so possible oh my god he has to
run right now he's gonna be in there
with a knife
i don't think anyone's heard it he's on
the phone oh my god he's done it
right into the overtime and this is how
it starts what a next level play
and he recently overtook zip x as the
player with the most secured clutches
in cs go apex is now leading the team
and
young french talent masuda has joined
the roster vitality has risen to be a
top 10 team in the hltv rankings albeit
at a time of uncertainty
and predominantly online play but
regardless of circumstance
french cs is back shocks is once again
positioned as
a key part of france's greatest hope and
maybe now without the burden of
leadership he can get back to fragging
out
but sharks is patient at the moment
poison
oh my god he runs through his own
molotov making the kill even easier
a fade away frag and one back the other
way he's just gonna be looking to play
this post playing he needs headshots and
he's gone
[Music]
keeping vitality in this shocks has been
to every cs
go major and won one for himself and for
france
his career is one that has inspired
gasps kerrigan instead with a double and
now sharks
it's all on him he tries he cancels out
a beautiful spray
it's all on shocks he picks up one
luminosity in
overtime he's looking for the shot
shark's gonna pick up one more
triple for him oh he gets the quad kill
are you kidding me
and heartbreak now shocks and rpk again
will be asked the same question
flusher running the corner now he's got
an opportunity and even without armor we
can see
dennis moves in he finds the final kill
in a full
save but that's
that you can only summarize that round
with closing in on 30 it would be
easy to assume that his greatest
achievements now lie in the past
but it's always been a bad bet to doubt
shocks when the odds
are against him
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell
for unique bite size videos you won't
find anywhere else hit up our instagram
twitter and facebook pages